people are understanding that robot
systems don't exist in a vacuum that our
robots regardless of what they do are
going to have to interact with humans at
the end of the day these advances that
we're seeing in computer vision where
we're able to very very rapidly detect
people's facial expressions or people's
body posture through things like open
pose have enabled our systems to get the
data that they need in order to
interpret human social behavior and then
on the human robot interaction side all
of these you know many studies coming
out that are trying to understand how
people interact with robots in various
ways and how robots can interpret human
behavior and use their own social
behavior to improve the interactions
between human and robot and so on the
production and understanding side the
human robot interaction research is
going to play a big part my vision for
the future is that technology has a
positive impact we have to answer
questions about how our technology could
be used for good and could be used for
bad and how we can aim our technological
advances toward positive impact in the
world I think this really means that we
need to be multidisciplinary need to
pull in lawyers and policy makers and
people from social sciences and we also
need to pull in people from technology
who understand the capabilities of these
systems and understand what's even
possible to talk about in in terms of
the societal impact
you